todo parece indicar que jamie con ibagué
tendrá una silla en la corte suprema
los republicanos le abrieron el camino a
la jueza conservadora justo antes de las
elecciones presidenciales
dv snow way no hay manera en la que me
convenzan que en mi bar no está
calificada y está utilizando estándares
de calificación los demócratas por su
parte acusan a los republicanos de
hipocresía barack obama fracasó en su
intento de poner a algún candidato al
tribunal durante su último año de
gobierno y el senado controlado por los
republicanos bloqueó a su nominado
hinchas que ustedes escogieron hacer
esto en medio de las elecciones así que
vayan y voten eso es lo que pasa porque
esta no debió ser una jueza propuesta
por donald trump
los senadores pusieron a barrett al
límite durante cuatro días ella evitó
responder preguntas relacionadas con la
discriminación el cambio climático los
derechos reproductivos de las mujeres
entre otros varios críticos temen que
ella pueda modificar el derecho a
abortar garantizado en la decisión
roe versus wait de 1973
déjenme intentar de nuevo ustedes están
de acuerdo con la opinión del juez
cali a que la decisión road fue erróneo
senadora yo entiendo completamente por
qué usted pregunta ese sin embargo de
nuevo yo no me puedo comprometer a decir
si yo voy a modificar algunos aspectos
porque no lo haré no tengo ninguna
agenda al respecto no tengo una
directriz que trate de imponerse sobre
casey
yo tengo una agenda que se apega al
ejercicio de la ley y decide causas a
medida que llegan afuera del capitolio
un puñado de simpatizantes de la jueza y
decenas de críticos expresaron su rabia
un panel controlado por los republicanos
en un senado controlado también por
ellos está previsto a votar sobre su
nominación el 22 de octubre esto
significaría que en miconi barrett
podría ser confirmada en su nuevo cargo
justo una semana antes de las elecciones
presidenciales